benvenuti a tutti quanti
oggi siamo su un gioco un po diversa chi
nella vita ha sempre calpestato i
sentimenti delle scarpe
io sempre oggi ci focalizziamo sulla
triste vita delle scarpe pensate che
ogni giorno vengono calpestate è una
cosa orribile e quindi scarpe simulator
vedo è proprio un gioco bellissimo e
giochiamo ecco questa è la mia madre
come mi chiedeva la porta di camera
quando cercavo troppo alla playstation
brutti momenti della mia infanzia
drammatico che questo dovrebbe essere un
horror in teoria fatto anche bene quindi
potrebbe essere trovarsi che ci siano
più episodi di questa cosa ha tra
l'altro c'è l'animazione iniziale quindi
fatto veramente figo l'ho pagato 20 euro
se fa schifo mi butto là balcone siamo
in america bene importante mettere
subito in chiaro le cose non rendiamo
subito il video non family friendly
maledizione prova con ragazzi vi ho
giocato un sacco ad and simulator se
avete presente cioè mi riesce a mettere
i preti che è difficilissimo come fa
quel gioco era veramente l'inferno mi
scusi le ho preso le scarpe non so se le
dà fastidio
va beh mammamia rega ma ve l'avevamo mai
visto un inizio così che il gioco da
madonna c'è più o meno
bene spero io video vi sia piaciuto come
al solito lasciato un bel mi piace e
commentate con le vostre impressioni il
video non è finito qua
che strano mi sono sparato da solo sono
ancora vivo ecco avete presente negli
horror quando si inizia che non si sa
come ci si è arrivati in quel punto ecco
questo caso è ancora peggio cioè non si
sa come ci siamo arrivati e c'è una
intro che ancora più brutta del normale
di ovino ci siamo ragazzi c'è una
grafica incredibile però doha pronto
pizza da quattro formaggi un'acqua
minerale grazie cosa posso andare avanti
la donna agli anziani mai prenderei un
orologio del genere in casa mia a dio
mio permesso sanità e quindi quando la
sanità è bassa succedono cose strane va
bene cavolo che gioco bellissimo è fatto
veramente da dio ce l'avevamo mai vista
una roba fatta così bene cioè un'amnesia
moderno gli eventi paranormali
succederanno randomicamente durante il
gioco
ap rosso rifletto posso riparare le
lampadine sto male meglio anche casa
enorme è questa amici suscita posso
uscire c'è il vetro esce spero che non
ci sia niente ha comunque fatto
veramente benissimo ed ai bastardi e
sarò da solo che stiamo placement ti va
bè piano di sopra ha permesso madonna
che bel bagno ci vivrei maestà casa
perché chicago in mano però non c'è
nulla dietro la vasca molto strano per
solo nord no no
no maledizione la luce il bagno ma c'è
una torcia qualche mamma mia che buio
con del buio
raga e non vedo niente jamie
servirebbero una torcia ce l'avete una
torcia salve ma io posso proseguire
anche senza torcia questo di perché
veramente buio raga
datemi qualcosa o qualsiasi rob ha messo
su una porta nella porta uno sgabuzzino
so good eye trovato un panda disegnato
va bene la messa alimentario delle
chiavi
il capitolo di lussi permesso ma ma mai
è che c'è un panda gigante via la stanza
del panda non vedo niente o pillole
pillole pillole su pillole ecco ecco
prendi premere usa bunert pillole
perfetto di ieri a cenni accendi la
smettiamo di aprire le porte a caso
clock knorr e la madonna cessata
dall'altra parte della porta bellissimo
l'importante è saper non lo prendi
disegno come come chiusa ci sono entrato
io da qua come signor demonio mi apre la
porta per fornola veramente chiusa come
fate entrare se chiusano è possibile no
no farc agate
ragazzi sta succedendo no come come
allora che non posso andare al bullismo
ma non ho neanche le le la torcia non
vedo niente
tornai prestate una torcia torcia il
bagno chiuso e aperto mamma mia che buio
via via via via qualcuno sta salendo le
scale sono scemo io ho sentito una roba
brutta messo vabbè ci mettete anche voi
sti poster noi siamo a posto insieme a
poster come sono simpatico ma si
appresta supporto non era aperta prima
permesso si aprono portin sto gioco cosa
mettiamo mettiamo fiorello
no no no oggi gesù
grazie a dio
gesù non sto ca per questa porta così a
stanza qua scusa vedo l'ora che non ho
capito dove da dove c'è una chiave che è
la chiave del basement della cantina
figurative c'è una cantina ha sottoposto
a the basement chi si sia la cantina
diciamo che non è proprio il posto
idilliaco dove passerà il pepero perché
nelle foto c'è uno che sembra uscita da
happy days
prima di andare a vedere ep days di
sotto abbiamo sempre dalla chiara usiamo
le chiavi
non è vero ok ok ok vi posso usarlo come
lo uso molto bene eccolo che cercavo
prima una torcia sarebbe meglio ma va
bene c'è più spiega i perché per passare
dare la sala la cucina c'è la cantina di
mezzo cioè gesù attento la tv è la
chiave della cantina apre qualsiasi cosa
in suo gioco e quindi scegliamo in
cantina ragazzi era solo per capire come
ha fatto la cantina collega tutta la
casa va bene va bene faceva un più
brutto stop basement in genere sono
tutti di legno difatti dopo la morte
invece noi c'è un'altra casa nel
basement è fighissimo
se non ci fosse il demonio dietro la
tenda o finalmente una zona allegra
messo ci hanno provare i soddisfano
stranissimo
vabbè c'è un altro salita ha messo il
light art raga la luce la luce luce
nuovo la luce spenta aspettava accendino
no non vedo niente via via via via sono
scherza mi serve la centro cittadino
come si accende porco demonio morto
inventario server non c'è la cd lo slow
perso per social il boom mortacci mia ma
non puoi andare lo stesso chissenefrega
passi dai era solo il giro del posto
mica mi sembrava di andare chissà dove e
quando certi lo sapremo
no no no no no no mi rif
mi rifiuto miri giuro non lo farò mai
no ragazzi ovviamente questo potrebbe
essere un problema e candele prendi
tutto prendi tutto o prendi bravissimo
prendi tutto chi se ne frega vai vai
vabbè lo so cosa siano le candele me
l'hanno insegnato non davo due anni va
avanti
ok
eccoli fondo cos'è cos'è che opero in
fondo li o mio dio non ho mica visto via
io devo uscire devo uscire da quella da
quella porta li devo uscire io devo
uscire da quella porta quella porta li
chiudi quella porta va là chiudi quella
porta via di questa porta questa porta
qui non si apre non si apre andare a
destra destra non devo andare a destra
devo andare a destra non mi non mi
saltare addosso per cortesia
insomma lasciato sorridi per facebook
vabbè
entrata nel muro questo successo va bene
grazie di avermi lasciato una siringa a
roma si smaterializza molto bene sono
molto più contento così vado esco ciao
perché vi giuro che da un moro che sento
qualcuno massi mare in lontananza ma non
capisco chi è prendi prendi questo
quindi questo le pillole pisa e prendi
la prendi a prenderla io sto bene sto
bene ho preso il pillole digiuno si
prossima
ma va vanti un lo vado a chi sei
ma chi 66 una roba sparisci pure ok ok
un gioco allegro era un ora che sentivo
anzi mare vabbè ok qui quando sento
ansimare una persona prendere le pillole
chiaro continua nel prossimo episodio è
veramente figo ci ha fatto benissimo e
ci si mette anche un sacco di ansia
la verità però vabbè però che vi sia
piaciuto a me più o meno farlo mi piace
anche per i social con iscrizione se non
sapessi di schiavi e non ci vediamo
[Musica]